ya hemos hablado acerca de la definición
de la vida media y como sabemos se
representa con una t y un medio por aquí
abajo y es el tiempo que se tarda la
concentración de un reactivo en
reducirse a la mitad de la concentración
inicial ok ya hablamos de esto en algún
vídeo anterior y también hemos hablado
de la ley de la velocidad integrada para
reacciones de segundo orden y eso es
justo lo que tenemos por aquí aunque
también conocida como la ecuación
integrada de la velocidad de la reacción
pero bueno como calculamos hace un par
de vídeos si tenemos una reacción de
segundo orden 1 entre la concentración
del reactivo al tiempo t menos 1 entre
la concentración inicial de ese reactivo
es igual a la constante de velocidad por
el tiempo aunque hay este mismo tiempo
voy aquí
ok esta es una de las formas de la ley
de la velocidad integrada para
reacciones de segundo orden
pero bueno si estamos hablando de la
vida media y ponemos el tiempo igual a
la vida media y lo sustituimos en la
ecuación también tenemos que averiguar
cuánto vale la concentración de a al
tiempo te iguala la vida media pero
cuánto vale la concentración de a en la
vida media pues por la misma definición
de lo que significa la vida media la
concentración de a en la vida media
tiene que ser igual a la mitad de la
concentración inicial o sea que tenemos
que poner por aquí la concentración
inicial
videla entre dos así es que tenemos que
sustituir este aquí bueno ya que vamos a
sustituir estas dos cosas
veamos cómo queda la ecuación tenemos
por aquí 1 entre la concentración de a
en la vida media que es la concentración
inicial de a sobre 2 concentración
inicial de a sobre 2 - menos 1 sobre la
concentración inicial de a 1 sobre la
concentración inicial de a y eso es
igual a la constante de velocidad de la
reacción por el tiempo pero el tiempo lo
estamos sustituyendo por la vida media
ósea
un medio ahora esto de aquí se puede
simplificar y es justo lo que vamos a
hacer 1 entre la concentración inicial
de a entre 2 es igual a 2 sobre la
concentración inicial de a aunque
tenemos menos 1 sobre la concentración
inicial de a igual a la constante de
velocidad por la vida media y esto de
aquí pues tenemos el mismo denominador y
nos queda 2 menos uno o sea uno sobre la
concentración inicial de a la
concentración inicial de a y es igual
acá por la vida media acá por la vida
media
y ya podemos encontrar la vida media que
hoy tenemos que la vida media es igual
nada más pasamos dividiendo la acá y nos
queda 1 sobre la constante de velocidad
por la concentración inicial del
reactivo
lo que tenemos aquí es la ecuación de la
vida media de una reacción de segundo
orden y observa que la vida media de una
reacción de segundo orden es muy
diferente a la vida media de una
reacción de primer orden ok
porque por ejemplo la vida media de una
reacción de segundo orden depende de la
concentración inicial a diferencia de la
vida media de las reacciones de primer
orden que eran constantes y no dependían
de la concentración inicial
aquí en estas reacciones de segundo
orden la vida media no es constante
porque depende de la concentración
inicial y vamos a ver por aquí la
gráfica de la concentración de un
reactivo con respecto al tiempo de una
reacción de segundo orden para entender
un poco mejor cómo funciona la vida
media en reacciones de segundo orden
así es que pues veamos cuando el tiempo
es igual a cero
la concentración de a el tiempo cero
está como por aquí porque esta es la
concentración inicial de a y bueno pues
vamos a inventar una reacción vamos a
decir que tenemos una concentración
inicial de ocho puntos entonces tenemos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 puntitos digamos que
dejamos que pase suficiente tiempo como
para que la concentración de crezca a la
mitad y entonces pues tenemos cuatro
puntitos nada más y ahora nos gustaría
saber cuánto tiempo se tardó en pasar de
ocho moléculas a cuatro moléculas y para
averiguarlo pues vamos a utilizar esta
gráfica ok empezamos por aquí con una
concentración inicial de 8 moléculas y
por acá tenemos la mitad de la
concentración inicial walker que está
justo a la mitad y entonces tomamos este
punto y nos vamos en línea recta hasta
la gráfica
y luego de la gráfica al eje del tiempo
y como podemos observar se tardó un
segundo entonces nuestra vida media en
este pedazo de tiempo de aquí duró un
segundo ok y bueno ahora queremos saber
cuánto tiempo dura la segunda vida media
nunca y tenemos por aquí cuatro
moléculas y queremos saber cuánto tiempo
se tarda la reacción en terminar con dos
moléculas de nuestro reactivo que
queremos saber cuánto tiempo se tarda en
pasar de cuatro moléculas a dos
moléculas así es que ahora la
concentración inicial es este valor de
aquí y queremos saber cuánto tiempo se
tarda la reacción en llegar a la mitad
de esa concentración y la mitad de esta
concentración es la concentración de a
el tiempo cero entre 4
y podemos saber en qué tiempo de la
reacción obtenemos esta concentración
del reactivo a tomando una línea recta
hacia la gráfica y desde este punto
bajando una perpendicular al eje x que
es donde están los tiempos como podemos
observar el tiempo t igual a tres
segundos el reactivo a tiene esta
concentración entonces cuánto tiempo se
tardó la reacción en pasar de cuatro
moléculas a dos moléculas pues se tardó
en este tiempo de aquí que son dos
segundos que hay dos segundos así es que
la segunda vida media de esta reacción
son dos segundos que es el doble de lo
que duró por acá cuando teníamos ocho
moléculas ahora esto lo podemos entender
directamente de la fórmula de la vida
media markt ahí sí tenemos que la
primera vida media fue de un segundo si
ahora utilizamos esta misma fórmula para
calcular la segunda vida media no case
segunda vida media la segunda vida media
es igual como tenemos aquí 1 entre la
constante de velocidad de la reacción
pero como estamos con la segunda vida
media la concentración inicial no es
esta de aquí ok
esta no es la concentración inicial la
concentración inicial es esta de aquí
cuando teníamos cuatro moléculas en
lugar de ocho aunque hay entonces la
concentración inicial cuando estamos en
la segunda vida media es esto de aquí ok
pero pues esto se simplifica a dos entre
cada por la concentración inicial de a y
listo ya tenemos la segunda vida media y
como podemos observar esta segunda vida
media mide exactamente el doble que la
vida media entonces si la vida media
duró un segundo la segunda vida media
tiene que durar dos segundos
entonces observando la gráfica podemos
ver que tiene sentido y analizando las
ecuaciones también tiene sentido así es
que la segunda vida media mide el doble
que la primera vida media pero ahora
pensemos qué pasará con la tercera vida
media
bueno pues tenemos que cada vida media
va a durar el doble que la vida media
anterior entonces cuando pasemos de dos
moléculas a una molécula nuestra
concentración inicial es de dos
moléculas y es esta de aquí pero si
nuestra concentración inicial es ésta la
mitad de nuestra concentración inicial
es esta de aquí sacamos una línea recta
para encontrarnos con la gráfica y de la
gráfica bajamos una perpendicular al eje
del tiempo y entonces como podemos
observar al tiempo t igual a 7
tenemos una molécula que es la mitad de
dos moléculas
entonces cuál es la tercera vida media
pues la tercera vida media es este
pedazo de tiempo
siete menos tres son cuatro segundos la
tercera vida media dura cuatro segundos
que es el doble de los dos segundos que
dura la segunda vida media ahora qué más
podemos interpretar de todo esto pues
bueno lo que podemos ver aquí es que en
las primeras etapas de tu reacción
cuando tienes más reactivos pues tienes
una mayor concentración de estos
reactivos y entre mayor sea la
concentración de los reactivos estas
moléculas pueden chocar entre sí mejor y
reaccionar más rápido y entonces la
reacción tiene una mayor velocidad
porque hay entre mayor sea la
concentración de los reactivos mayor es
la velocidad de esta reacción y entonces
los reactivos se consumen más rápido y
por lo tanto tenemos una vida media más
corta nunca hay entre más rápida es una
reacción menos tiempo se tarda en
consumir la mitad de los reactivos
porque hay menos tiempo se tarda
en llegar a la mitad de la concentración
inicial